walking into the gardens at Buckingham
Palace it has only been a week since he
announced he wants to step back from
this kind of life in many ways it was
the Prince Harry that we all know joking
about not wanting to annoy the Queen but
we couldn't help wonder if this could be
the last time we'd see him at a royal
event like this as he avoided the other
subject we know has upset his
grandmother it has always been an issue
for the Royals trying to make sure their
private lives don't overshadow events
the draw for the Rugby League World Cup
probably got more attention because the
extra interest in their patron as he
tried to stick to the safe subject of
sport the impact that it has especially
on young people but the impact that has
on the individuals plane but the
community as a whole is remarkable and
not only do I continue to see sport
actually changing lives and it's saving
lives as well this video message about
mental health was the second that he's
released this week I'm proud to support
the Rugby League World Cup 2021 mental
Fitness chaucer another for the Invictus
games gave us a sign of what still
matters to him the Invictus games will
travel to a new country a new home for
respect for our artists
it's not clear exactly how he's going to
be able to do it when he's moving
between the UK and Canada but his
charity partners are hopeful they'll
keep him as a passionate supporter I
have no doubt at all that he will
continue to support the Invictus games
as he has done for the last six years
irrespective of what roles he has going
forward with the royal family
Prince Harry may have been trying to act
like it was just business as usual but
behind the scenes Palace staff and civil
servants are still working around the
clock to try and iron out those details
about how this new life for him and the
Duchess is really going to work and
that's why the international interest
around them is showing no sign of dying
down especially with Megan in Canada and
another women's group releasing photos
of a visit that she made earlier this
week
their latest Instagram post another sign
this is a couple who want to take
control of their future as we wait to
see how things will unfold this once
playful Prince Rhiannon Mills Sky News
at Buckingham Palace